I guess okay little update to my video I
guess I'm not the kind of guy who makes
things simple I don't think I make
things simple I think I make them I try
to make them easier to understand
simplifying would be like taking things
out and being like okay well let's not
bother with these complicated things
let's just tell a simplified version of
the story I don't try to tell a
simplified version of the story I try to
make the whole story easier to
understand and I I'm
I I hope that whenever we succeed at
that I'm very proud of it uh but I think
that those are two different things and
I think that that's an interesting thing
to think
about okay bye